the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I have here first part is just the
top part so I have some blank line and
then I'm defining a method named speak
so write a line to replace blank that
creates a class for a dog that inherits
from animal ok so the first thing I
notice is that I need to write a
definition for a class whose name is dog
so my choices are these so I can I can
tell it's either the first or the third
one and then I want to inherit from
animal so I don't want to inherit from
object but I want to inherit from animal
right so that's perfect next question
says with this definition of dog you run
a program with those three lines what
happens okay so this is my definition
and I have these three lines let's go
down here nice okay so with these three
lines it says this first line says D is
equal to dog 7 so I'm creating a dog
object with age 7 is this is a line
going to throw an error well this line
actually looks for an init method this
particular class definition doesn't have
a init method but hey I'm inheriting
from someone I'm inheriting from animal
does animal have an init method and it
does as we saw in the slides okay so
we're creating a new dog with age 7 and
name none next so that line doesn't
throw an error the next line sets the
name to ruffles and again I don't have a
set name method inside this particular
class but does my animal class my parent
class have a setname method and yes it
does right here so I call that one so
that line does not throw an error and
the third line says d dot speak which
which is going to cause python to look
in this current class definition and it
says hey I have a method here named
speak so I'm gonna use this one and it's
going to print ruff ruff because it's a
method so you can
yeah so you can just it's like a
function you can just print things you
don't need to return anything so perfect
most of you are getting that right